this dashcam video shows a sheriff's
deputies stopping an impaired wrong-way
driver flying down a Texas Highway a
number of Americans killed each year in
wrong-way crashes has increased more
than 38 percent since 2013 wrong-way
collisions are 50 times more likely to
be deadly compared to all vehicle
crashes Kris Van Cleave shows us how
Arizona is investing in a possible
high-tech solution that instantly alerts
police and drivers good morning there
should be no question that you're going
the wrong way but states are finding
good signage and even common sense isn't
enough to always stop a wrong-way driver
from getting on a freeway and the
consequences can be deadly seconds from
disaster
this driver swerves to avoid a wrong-way
driver
cell phone video caught this truck
plowing into oncoming traffic on i-25 in
Colorado here Tennessee police drove
straight into a wrong-way driver to stop
her how big of a problem is it for us
it's it's a huge problem
Arizona State Troopers Stewart McGuffin
says he'll never forget the night he
came face-to-face with a wrong-way
driver who fortunately stopped I don't
want him to go around me I don't want to
get in a wreck I don't want to get hurt
but you know I really don't want that
car getting around me and colliding with
unknowing or unsuspecting traffic it has
to be a terrifying moment yeah
how often do you get a call for a
wrong-way driver every day every shift
there is a call
mostly shift every shift Colonel Frank
Milstead oversees Arizona's Highway
Patrol sixty-five percent of all those
people that we stop and arrest for going
the wrong way are impaired it's not a
highway problem it's an impairment
problem it's hard as a mother to know
that your child's gone before you and
they haven't been able to fulfill all
their dreams Maryann Mendoza's son
Brandon a Mesa police sergeant died four
years ago when a drunk driver hit him
head-on
she's now suing the state quit talking
about doing something about it because
there's still wrong-way drivers on the
freeways and they're still Arizona
citizens who at risk who could be killed
today Arizona is the first state testing
thermal cameras to catch wrong-way
drivers posted at freeway off-ramps
along a 15 mile stretch of Interstate 15
to immediately spot a wrong-way driver
entering the freeway part of a 4 million
dollar pilot project when triggered that
alarm sounds in the Department of
Transportation Operations Center it
brings up the camera and alerts police
to the drivers location within seconds
freeway sign boards warn wrong-way
driver ahead exit freeway faster we can
react the better off we are
Dallas Hammond is a dots deputy director
so you know almost instantly that it's
happened how does that compare to
waiting for a 9-1-1 call in one case we
got an alert we saw it on our camera and
we waited almost 5 minutes before the
911 call Arizona also took a page from
San Antonio which saw the rate of
wrong-way drivers entering a highway
drop by about a third after enlarging
and lowering wrong-way signs and adding
ones like this that light up and flash
red research shows there is not an
effective way to stop a wrong-way driver
from getting on a freeway right now we
have not found a physical barrier that
stops them we've looked at spikes we've
looked at other things and they just
aren't reliable Maryann Mendoza tends to
her son's memorial at the ballpark this
city named after him it's a way for her
to hold on to his men
she just hopes no other mother
experiences her heartbreak I just know
what hard work he put into this and the
plans he had for himself in the future
you know and they're gone other states
are now coming to Arizona to see how
this pilot program is working the state
is planning to expand it adding these
cameras to a new stretch of freeway set
to open next year for CBS this morning
Kris Van Cleave Phoenix Chris thanks
let's hope those new measures work